[Musica]
in molti pensano che il lavoro del cuoco
non è un lavoro per donne ed è per
questo che ci sono poche donne chef
perché un lavoro di forza aveva detto lo
chef vissani a dicembre le donne non
riescono a sollevare pentoloni pesanti
dopo un po crollano mollano
perché un lavoro estenuante e
psicologicamente stressante pensano in
molti
d'altronde lavori non meno di 12 ore al
giorno e se ti va bene
il fatto è che pure i numeri parlano
chiaro
è vero molte poche donne avanzano nella
carriera in cucina
se prendiamo come campione i ristoranti
stellati michelin al mondo è
sorprendente notare come solo il 4 per
cento siano guidati da chef donne
pochissimi perché le risposte più comuni
a questa domanda che troviamo anche solo
digitando sul web perché ci sono poche
donne chef sono tre una no perché le
cucine professionali sono dei luoghi
prettamente maschili dove le donne fanno
fatica ad inserirsi sono soggette a
battute sessiste fanno fatica a
comunicare ea farsi rispettare
2 perché la donna entrata nel mondo del
lavoro relativamente da pochi decenni e
quindi il fatto che ci siano poche donne
chef sarebbe un retaggio culturale del
passato
3 c'è una difficoltà oggettiva con tutte
quelle varie di lavoro come fai ad avere
figli ea prendersene cura
io credo che queste risposte siano tutte
e tre vere
eppure mi se non mi sembrano del tutto
sufficienti per dar conto di una
percentuale così bassa da il 4 per cento
è ridicolo
16 niamo alla percentuale di donne che
negli stati uniti guidano gli aerei ma
dico guidano gli aerei come stiamo
parlando di qualcosa di un'attività che
noi donne svolgiamo dalla notte dei
tempi cioè cucinare e che queste tre
risposte non siano del tutto sufficienti
mi pare evidente del fatto che oggi
molti lavori prima esclusivamente
maschili sono svolti da donne competenti
che sono imprenditrici manager avvocati
e tanto altro è che se vogliono possono
coniugare anche la vita privata io credo
in questa in questa sede io vorrei
provare ad avanzare una quarta ipotesi
di risposta mi sembra che ci sia
qualcosa nel modo di intendere la
professione di chef oggi professione che
sta tra l'altro avendo un successo
inedito qualcosa che impedisce rallenta
alle donne la possibilità di fare
carriera ed emergere
credo che questo qualcosa vada cercato
nel concetto di creatività che cosa si
richiede lo chef oggi di essere creativo
a cosa aspira il giovane cuoco oggi ad
avere il proprio ristorante diventare
uno chef esprimere la propria creatività
e dunque realizzarsi
sembra quasi che la creatività sia il
ponte verso una realizzazione personale
in questa società se sei un genio
creativo tiravi dalla mediocrità e poi
pure fare soldi e in quanto creativo
qualcosa di simile ad un artista che lo
chef è diventato una star
oggi è questa creatività a che fare con
lo stupore l'emozione la genialità ma
cos'è la creatività davvero a che fare
ha davvero legata a doppio filo con la
meraviglia con il
famoso effetto wow con l'esprimersi del
genio individuale dell'artista chef
io credo di no o forse credo che ci
siano tante accezioni di creatività e mi
sembra che questa in particolare sia
legata al maschile
permettetemi di generalizzare un po mi
sembra che si fonde su di un insieme di
valori che fanno più parte del carattere
maschile rispetto a quello femminile
mi sembra un modello legato alle
dinamiche di una società costruita su
due generi il maschile e il femminile e
mi sembra che questo modello sia
veicolato già nell'infanzia attraverso i
giochi e l'educazione ai bambini vengono
insegnati i giochi dove tiri fuori la
tua forza la tua sicurezza di sé il
fatto che l'idea di conquista di
competizione di sicurezza fanno i
bambini viene insegnato a giocare con le
bambole ad essere brave pazienti carine
non aggressive al massimo a risolvere a
gestire delle situazioni complesse in
modo diligente le bambine l'educazione
delle bambine qualcosa che ha poco a che
vedere con questa creatività competitiva
affermativa
non è un caso che la storia della cucina
in cui progressivamente si afferma
questa idea
questo l'imperativo della creatività
geniale sia una storia fatta di uomini
nell'ottocento insieme all'affermarsi
dell'artista genio si delinea anche
l'immagine del cuoco artista e poi è nel
novecento fino all'inizio 2000 in cui
vediamo delinearsi l'immagine tutta
maschile di mostro sacro della cucina
pensiamo a bo chiuse ma dukas fino
arrivare a quel gran genio che è stato
fermo
lo spagnolo ferran adrià con ferran
adrià viene lanciato l'imperativo
assoluto della genialità in cucina da
ferran in poi il grande chef è
l'inventore geniale che rompe gli schemi
tutti gli altri sono pochi su questo
argomento argomenti ho riflettuto molto
anche perché io lavoro con il mio
compagno che chef anche lui e che su che
nel mondo della cucina è considerato e
forse si considera particolarmente
creativo da questo in questa accezione
del termine e quante volte sono stata
accolta dalla sindrome dell'impostore
sicuramente tutte le volte che ho vinto
dei premi e mi dicevo ma dai ma ci sarà
qualcuna o qualcuno più creativo di me e
ci ho messo del tempo a capirlo ma poi
alla fine l'ho capito che il problema
stava proprio lì in quel concetto di
creatività legata al genio che poteva
essere messo in discussione
io credo che sia abbastanza diffuso in
questa società e credo anche che le
donne dovrebbero liberarsi da questo
senso di insicurezza e di incapacità nei
confronti di un tale modello è trovare
la propria dimensione
volendo anche creativa come chef se in
molti settori tra cui quello della
ristorazione ma attenzione non quello
della cucina che sono diversi
il contributo delle leadership femminili
ha riconosciuto ormai come al portatore
di miglioramenti e funzionalità nelle
aziende io credo che questo nella cucina
non sia ancora accaduto proprio perché
il modello dominante si basa su questo
concetto di creatività legata al genio
che rimane tutto sommato modello
maschile
allora quale creatività io non ho una
risposta unica forse nessuna forse
tantissime io so solo che non mi sento
un genio creativo ma che riconosco oggi
la mia forza
nella fantasia costante del pensare
piatti menu la mia cucina nel prendermi
cura del cliente delle persone
dell'esperienza culinaria nel fare della
cucina e della tecnica culinaria uno
strumento per vivere appieno interagire
rispettare la natura i suoi prodotti
l'ambiente in cui viviamo
voglio fare un piccolo esempio che è
solo un esempio di un modo di fare o di
una creatività in cucina noi da
quest'anno siamo riusciti ad eliminare
la plastica usa e getta in cucinare o
quasi un mezzo miracolo togliendoci di
torno sacchetti sottovuoto e pellicola
io lo vedo come uno degli atti su cui si
può puntare l'attenzione per esempio ora
credo che ci sia un traguardo da
raggiungere su cui tutti siamo d'accordo
è necessario aumentare la percentuale di
donne chef e per fare questo forse
necessario far crollare un modello che è
stato il ponte per un successo
prevalentemente maschile e aprire delle
vie funzionali anche al successo
femminile
si potrebbe ad esempio cominciare a
pensare la cucina come una tecnica che
può avere dei risultati altissimi e non
solo come un'arte vincolata alla
genialità del singolo i media le guide
potrebbero aiutarci in questo aprire
spazi a nuovi linguaggi scompigliare un
po le carte dei generi non limitarsi a
dare i premi con le quote rosa
credo quindi per finire che liberarsi da
certi valori di genialità potrebbe
permettere a molte più donne di fare
successo ed emergere in cucina e credo
che potrebbe essere un cambiamento
innovativo trainante anche perché no per
l'intera società grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]